de la alfombra roja a la cárcel tarané
alidosti considerada una de las mejores
actrices de Irán fue detenida este
sábado por las autoridades de su país el
motivo del arresto fue una publicación
en sus redes sociales la actriz se
solidarizó con el primer manifestante
ejecutado este último participó en las
protestas por la muerte de Masha mini
que murió de manos de la policía de la
moral el pasado 16 de septiembre su
nombre era Moisés cada organización
internacional que observa este
derramamiento de sangre y no toma
medidas es una vergüenza para la
humanidad la cuenta de la actriz donde
mostraba su simpatía con los
manifestantes iraníes con unos ocho
millones de Seguidores fue suspendida
según medios estatales la artista fue
capturada porque no portó fundamento
alguno a sus afirmaciones Esta no es la
primera vez que la regencia de los
ayatolas detiene reconocidas
personalidades del país el pasado mes de
noviembre otras dos actrices y un
futbolista al que específicamente se le
acusó de hacer contra el gobierno
también fueron detenidos Irán vive un
período de descontentos sin precedentes
dejando miles de personas encarceladas y
dos ejecuciones oficiales como
escarmiento